where are we new HQ
live yeah so this is gonna be
um
a room you know I'm not sure yeah
reaction area maybe yeah I don't know
this is another
room
okay yeah yeah this is another wait for
it
room
no you know it's actually funny because
this was my parents office so growing up
I would come here and wait we're gonna
go this way growing up I would come here
and um
like as a kid I would come here after
school all the time and listen oh this
is a bathroom
and so yeah my parents they recently
sold their business and they said I
could use this for you know five
so this is I think we will probably this
is a smaller one so we'll probably put
like editors in here or something maybe
like reaction spaces maybe yeah I don't
know
um this is where
you know I lived here one summer
thumbnail picture taken there I did not
appreciate being late but whatever
um
it's fun it's so funny though because
it's like full circle like my parents
literally this was their
like this is where
um growing up like me and my siblings
would come after school and like I'd
watch my mom and dad work
um like entrepreneurship has just always
been big in my family this I don't know
I think
a reception area reception I guess
um
in here
you know this is the
meeting room so I guess you know we just
spent like a bunch of hours hashing out
stuff maybe this will be my office I was
thinking
they're my you know
I think this one
um this may be blessings office my
office Kobe's we'll see we'll see fight
for it I'll take upstairs then yeah
which office
today Toby what office do you want we'll
do a Three-Point Shootout
damn coffee gonna do me like that you
guys can rock paper scissors no we're
gonna go in the basketball court
we're sparring we're sparring we're
gonna go in the basketball court oh yeah
wonderful
um
yes this is the other one this is my
dad's office program
fun fact
yeah the one downstairs is nicer the
other one the one downstairs just has a
nice one okay I'll stay out there up
here with the cool people oh the cool
people yeah
you know I mean we learn about our
content creators guys you might get
booted
all right
I'll go back to the London location
Penthouse thingy oh but what the
location is way smaller right like I
like it it's a nice view though who
doesn't even ask you yes
they also just surprisingly approved us
to resign there we were shocked
yeah so um terrible decision on here
um yeah right so this is probably going
to be the new like
yeah
and the control room at the back
it's actually air conditioned unlike
London
um so we are going to be hiring you know
editors
um producers
um
Recruiters in Chicago so if you're in
the Chicago suburbs you know hit me up
there's a bathroom down here too
so funny
I'm back here
I thought I'd be back my parents people
can wait here before the shows you know
oh people can watch the shows in here we
can put a TV yeah yeah
it's so funny
the new network is coming out new name
everything yeah we have a new name
coming out
and you can watch this
McDonald's yeah we could hire whales
here yeah McDonald's
because my dad would work a lot so I
would come to the office and my dad
would be working I'd be like Dad Dad Dad
hang out with me now this may have
annoyed some of the people that works
here me yeah we were just these little
rugrat kids like running around doing
our thing but yeah my dad and I would
always walk to Subway down the street
you know
yeah that's the tour though
ouch
we're really gonna Ponder an idea
yes pondering
but yeah that's it that's the whole
place